contact
L rolling out that door is remarkably
stupid you don't go on contact left you
go out the other side my name is Eric
terashima I'm a retired colonel from the
United States Marines I spent 30 years
of service and had 12 deployments
including eight combat tours and three
of those were in Afghanistan today we
are going to look at Afghanistan War
battles in movies and judge how real
they are
Landing helicopters in Afghanistan uh
was challenging those look to me like a
ch47 Chinooks that was frequently used
by the Army heavy lift helicopter large
troop
transporter some of that looks enhanced
just for the movie to make it look more
dramatic an RPG bringing down a
helicopter uh is absolutely realistic
but it has to be a a very very lucky
shot like you just you hit a vital
system particularly in a very dramatic
crash like that I would give this clip
an eight the the stress and the duress
that that I felt coming through the
actors uh as well as the scenario that
was uh depicted so yeah this was they
did a pretty good
job being on horses would be beneficial
for fighting in Afghanistan because of
the uh the mountainous terrain you have
to go through a lot of uh elevation
changes hiking up hiking down and so
horses are going to help you gain more
distance more quickly as opposed to
wearing yourself out on foot later when
I started to go through some uh advisor
training this is up in the mountains uh
we would have classes on how to pack
mules for example and how to butcher
animals and have cook them out over an
open fire so yeah we we worked on some
of those skills hey where the hell do
those come
from how did do him not know about a
supply line lack of intelligence is what
he's concerned about like we we should
know this uh these are capital pieces of
equipment our networks are so strong in
the Spy world that they should have had
an idea of what was uh up ahead and
tanks are kind of a big deal they're
loud they travel long distances and
everyone should know where all of them
are the advantages are mobile armor uh
there so the occum are protected and
then a big gun that's a big Advantage uh
big disadvantage is that they are Road
bound and they can only go on certain
roads uh which makes them vulnerable uh
to mines like IEDs they had tanks they
were Soviet era uh tanks that were
available and usable by them by the time
I showed up the Coalition forces were so
strong that there's no way that the
enemy could possibly use tanks against
us
don't want support people standing up in
the middle of of a firefight it's like
you actually don't do that you want to
get down down on the ground right cuz
you don't want to get hit I would give
it a six for realism this particular
clip um on the horses is cool and
dramatic and yeah and they're charging
downhill uh but some of the individual
tactics kind of made me uh laugh a
little bit there's no logical reason for
Hadi to lead us down this Troth unless
he's leading us into a trap you're out
of your bounds Amed you're here to
translate actually I'm here to interpret
that's a really great response
interpreting is so much more than
translation translation just trying to
get the verbatim speech and convey that
interpreters are much more than that
they become uh cultural advisers uh to
the people that they're that they're
servicing with and um when you start
working closely with uh with your
interpreters it what happens is you need
to form trust with each other if you
don't build that trust then you may be
lacking in the ability to get a full
interpretation of what's Happening he's
saying I'm interpreting a cultural thing
right here that I that I I'm seeing I'm
seeing how Hadid is acting he's acting
weird and I'm sniffing the this guy out
he's being a rat and by the way even
though your sensors and your patrols and
stuff don't see it this is a bad road to
go down you do not want to do
this he's a traitor in Afghanistan and
actually in all cases we do have to vet
sources of uh intelligence what you do
is you try to confirm or deny
information that they give you as things
pass along in time and so over time you
build up okay how often is he lying to
us because you expect that and then how
and why that's what a case manager is
going to try to do that's how the beding
process
[Music]
goes I kind of call BS on that one if if
you're if he's going to draw a weapon
the one he's going to do is the rifle
that's around his shoulder uh and the
reason why you do that is because
pistols are wildly inaccurate you've
only got this much of a barrel a lot of
pistol fights go off you see like 20
rounds fired by each side all misses at
this kind of a range in various degrees
you always have to kind of diffus
tension of some sort is he doing a good
job um no if you're trying to deescalate
a situation drawing your pistol out is
not a
deescalation he says they have his
family the risk was uh pretty high uh
really high and particularly my my last
uh deployment was 2019 through 2020 I'm
in lash Gara and most of our
interpreters were locals from lash Gara
they would kind of sneak on and off the
base of fortunately we were collocated
with an Afghan base so made a that's a
very simple lie I'm going to go work on
The Afghan base come in and out not
knowing they're actually working for the
Coalition forces so we've got these
locals who are extremely at risk uh like
if their pictures get out their names
get out then their families get known
and their families do get threatened
obviously I'm I'm still concerned about
the ones who are left behind I still
send money uh reg on a regular basis to
multiple families out there they need
support and I I can't let my friends
starve I'd give it a four um mainly
because uh the scenario is common enough
what I don't like are the tactics person
who's trying to deescalate the situation
and instead does an escalatory move uh
which doesn't make any sense at all so
that's why I gave it a four just click
it don't change any settings just click
it vehicle amb bushes were uh very
common in Afghanistan because you're
confined to roads that can handle uh
that kind of load and because of this
kind of terrain it's up in the mountains
everything's is canalized you must go
through that road that makes it a lot
easier to Ambush Vehicles
contact contact left means that if I'm
here in the driver's seat that means I'm
receiving fire from my left hand side
yelling contact left and rolling out
that door is remarkably stupid you don't
go on contact left you go out the other
side
Stark should have stayed in the vehicle
because what usually will happen is as
you're forming defenses during an ambush
the vehicle actually becomes uh a safe
spot that's where your food is that's
where your water is that's where your
pack is you know your supplies and other
things so yeah the vehicle's absolutely
Central that does happen sometimes where
you'll have a nearby exploding piece of
ordinance and next to nothing happens to
you uh as opposed to
um you could just get like utterly
destroyed depending on where you show up
in the frag pattern is how that works
and this is just dumb luck I think I'd
give this one an eight there is going to
be a deduction for contact left getting
out left although people do do stupid
things uh when they're into rest Stark
should not have left the vehicle
either what he say you give them props
uh for not having doors on the Humvees
that's that's a good detail it's like
that's clearly early early on uh where
you were where you were doing stuff like
that
it would be common to to be in bomb out
buildings like that just standing out in
the open firing a bunch of rounds not
necessarily the smartest thing to do
you're looking for cover you're looking
for angles like don't stand right next
to each other I got you hands
up Lucky some hit your plate oh Jesus
when that metal hits your plate that's
like someone punching you in the chest
basically right so all that force
velocity and bullet are are hitting you
and so you just feel this giant thump
the tactics of the the shooting and
moving um don't make sense to me I I
think that could have been depicted a
little bit better so I'm going to give
it a
six
here the film portrays the Battle of
cames in 2009 that's an absolutely
horrible defensive position to be raid
down in the middle of the valley with
two steep Cliffs up above you with lots
of terrain that you can hide in one of
the first things you would do when you
occupy a position like this at least I
would do is write what's called a fir
plan sketch you put down all the places
in the terrain that's surrounding you
like a a ledge that an enemy can just
peek over what you would be able to do
with the sketch is from any position in
your defensive spot you would know okay
that Ridge right there is 200 yards away
from me and that makes a difference of
where you're going to aim or how you're
going to aim and with what weapon system
to down to down ah would it be realistic
to have a machine gun uh that's ready to
go under a tarp absolutely it would be
you'd prefer to have um somebody on the
machine gun at all times uh at least I I
would I would be doing at least one test
fire a day just to make sure all my
stuff was tight and ready and I would
have rounds at the ready any bit of
armor in the field helps especially cuz
this is a gunfight of yes you want you
want your personal protective equipment
on ceramic plate that's on your chest
and on your back is designed to stop a
762 two round at close range and that
kind of thing happened all the time
you're running operations 24 hours a day
you're going to have to have day
sleepers or people who are doing other
things people may be working out so
there's you go to the bathroom uh you
take a shower you're doing all these
things and you're 24 hours at risk so
yeah when something happens it's normal
to see folks in maybe their unlaced
boots with with the Flack and helmet on
that's all they got and their weapon
weather apach are down it'll be two more
hours that happens all the time the
terrain is is so drastic within
Afghanistan like here in this depiction
looks like it's kind of Sunny maybe a
little bit overcast but it the weather
doesn't look all that bad well when
mountain range away it could be just
like insane weather it could be a crazy
thunderstorm wind storm Sandstorm high
winds an Apache helicopter is an assault
aircraft carries a Gatling gun and it
carries uh Rockets it's highly
maneuverable it can get in and out of
the terrain and sometimes they they
already know before they're even coming
in what their targets may be looking
like cuz they may have gotten a
pre-brief it's an extra machine gun and
and Rocket Firepower that's highly
accurate I'll give it a nine it's really
good it's really well done you want to
take a look at this what what do you see
let me
see nice firewatch is a 24-hour man
position and it's firat because in the
Marines we hearken it back to you had to
have a fire and you need keep keep the
Embers going if you didn't you were
screwed he called it an OP so it's an
observation post that's why he's on the
binoculars binoculars uh are a whole lot
easier to hold up than having a rifle at
the ready and they also have a wide
wider field of view so if you want to be
able to scan large parts of the Horizon
binoculars are definitely the way they
would be doing that and you got
them typically want high up positions uh
high up positions uh give you better
fields of view they're longer uh you can
see more and in some cases like in this
particular one you've got a lot of
standoff between you and the other
folks no no no no
no very
B very very
bur Barry this is kind of a PTSD trigger
moment that this guy's going through
it's a really intense emotional feeling
like you're killing a human being and oh
by the way not you killed three and then
the guys who are with you are
celebrating like giddy celebrating which
is for your normal person being that up
close and personal to death is bizarre
one of the issues for me with PTSD is um
I get overly stimul stimulated you do
kind of have sometimes these out-of-
body experiences where where you're you
lose track of like okay this is not
really good for everyday people to hear
or be a part of it's a selective crowd
I'd give it a 10 I think it was a a good
uh depiction of ptsc absolutely
[Music]
absolutely so we call this victim
initiated was there a way to detect uh
IEDs in the field before them going off
yes absolutely so frequently what we
would do is a patrol like that would be
led by somebody sweeping the ground all
in this case for whatever reason they
they clearly did not do
that
see s off so RC is radio controlled kind
of like a a mine Ambush because it was a
Well well-worn Trail and it was a remote
control device of some sort something
got a signal so it was an active piece
that means down on that IED there needs
to be a power source it needs to be a
battery that way you got something to
close the circuit to detonate the ad the
device and uh something that would
receive that remote detonation piece how
far away does that person need to be
well if it's like a garage door opener
they got to be kind of close right uh to
get that kind of a distance uh if if
it's more sophisticated maybe they could
be further away that would be a just a
basic like a paintbrush same thing that
like archaeologists will use you might
do that if you're concerned about there
being um a trigger so if you're
concerned about that then yes you want
to be very careful around those
initiators on the other hand uh there's
been times in war where I've seen people
see detonation cord well if you're
walking around in an area like that and
you see a like a a red wire looking
thing that has no business being there
that's detonation cord that usually
means that somebody has set up a bomb
near you and so I've seen guys in the
field grab that that detonation cord and
just Yank on it uh right and reel in the
these bombs hope we good on this um
hostile
intend what you're talking about is
Rules of Engagement right when you can
and cannot shoot why you should or
should not shoot and uh establishing
hostile intent is one of those things
how do you determine that in this case
to to make it really easy on the
viewership it was this guy is putting a
bomb in the middle of the road that's
clearly designed for us I'm going to
give this a uh a
nine that's 100% realistic and happened
and it was funny cuz she's like hot hot
hot hot cuz yeah think about it you just
had an explosion happen in this little
chunk of metal it's hot when it comes
down so this people in a firefight who
were just standing up like what are you
doing you don't do that in the firefight
you get down cuz you don't want to get
shot at right you don't want to get hit
by a bullet so I'm laughing at that just
that the tactics don't make any sense um
if someone's shooting at you you're not
going to just stand there be like hey
yeah I like getting shot at this is
cool a javelin is like an anti-tank
weapon comes in two different modes
there's a direct fire mode and then
there's an over the-top mode which I
think this depicted the over the toop
mode one of the the funny things is that
um it requires a certain standoff it's
around 150 to 200 M well that truck was
not 150 to 200 met away so there's a
little bit of of that cinematography
that you just got to do for Hollywood
stuff uh I get so no points off on that
one for realism um I'll give it a three
most of the detraction is is just from
standing up while shooting uh you would
never do that my favorite scene that I
watched today was from The Outpost it
felt very real to me the duress of the
folks being put into a horrible
situation doing the best they can with
it pretty believable so I liked it from
that standpoint and if you like this
video why not click on the next
one